- Yo, what's up, guys? Nasher here coming to you from Seattle.
As you may know, there's a new NHL team in town.
And today we're showing you behind the scenes.
First things first, today it is bright and early here at 8:30 a.m.
The morning skate is getting ready to start up.
We're heading to the arena now, and we'll see what's going down.
We've just arrived here at Climate Pledge Arena.
It is looking beautiful from the
outside and even better here on the inside.
Ever wonder what it looks like to be on an NHL bench?
Well, we're out here chillin'.
Nice little touch here in Seattle. For each of their warm-up pucks,
we have the official warm-up puck: Seattle vs. New York.
So when you're taking home a puck from
the game, you know where it's from.
So Climate Pledge Arena is all about the environment, right?
This is a fully electric Zamboni. Usually when we're down here,
you smell the gasoline. It sounds very loud.
As you can see, quiet Zamboni. Smells perfect. Beauty.
And, of course, we have the Seattle Kraken locker room.
Now, there's some top-secret stuff going on there right now.
We're not able to enter, but let's walk down this tunnel behind you.
You just feel powerful walking down a tunnel like this.
Not only that, we have these crazy suites.
So Seattle had the optional skate before. The Rangers are in full force.
- [Artemi Panarin:] The Rangers comin'.
Not a lot of people have got to touch the
Seattle Kraken ice, and we are one of the few.
All of this ice is from reused rainwater.
They collect it. Bring it down here. Two Jumbos above us.
You just cannot beat these vibes.
Here we are
We're joined with Philipp Grubauer here of the Seattle Kraken.
You've had a good couple of games here.
You're starting tonight.
How you feeling?
- Pretty good.
It's amazing to play in here for sure.
- What's it been like in the locker room
kinda building a new culture here in Seattle?
- It's been unbelievable to be part of that process
and just to see the excitement in the city and
before we even started playing the first game here was incredible.
Playing a couple home games in a row, it's pretty cool and special,
and I think it translates to the excitement in the locker room for the guys as well.
- Tell me about the city of Seattle.
What's something we should go check out after the game tonight?
- Lake Union is incredible. Obviously go up the Space Needle.
If you have time, there's so many great spots.
You actually, you guys came in at the right time
because it's actually sunny today.
- Yeah.
- For the last week, it's only been raining.
So just drive around the lake.
I think that's pretty cool to see as
well. And Mount Rainier in the back,
it's pretty special.
- Awesome, man. Wish you the best of luck tonight.
Thanks again for everything.
And, uh, yeah.
Phil Grubauer here with the Seattle Kraken.
We explored the arena. We got on the ice.
We got to talk to our boy Grubauer.
What an unreal morning here in Seattle,
but now it is time to explore the rest of the city.
So we're going to go to the market.
We're going to grab some lunch.
Show you guys around.
We just saw the fish throw live in person.
This is where the Seattle Kraken announced their picks.
A fish came over, flipped it over. Bada bing!
Dude, it is a whole different world here in Seattle.
We got the cats on the violin. I don't know what is happening, but
this place is sick. Markets, food, flying fish. You name it, they have it.
We found a little card shop here at the market. The owner in there is super nice.
We're going to walk in, show you guys around and maybe buy a couple packs.
A lil' 1990 NHL Hockey cards.
Dude, the Seals. Those jerseys are the best.
All right, we've got our packs. We're gonna pop these open.
We'll see if we can recognize any of the
players in here, depending on who we get.
And a Mike Modano.
That is a banger. North Stars jersey and all.
Let's go grab some food. I'm starving.
So we explored the market, found some food. We're at Athenian here.
Beautiful-looking food, seafood alfredo.
We've got the fries. You can't beat the view.
Out there we've got the Ferris wheel, which I think we're gonna head to next.
Yeah, I don't think I've been on a
Ferris wheel since I was seven years old.
This is fire. Man, Seattle literally has it all.
We have made it to the top. Let's go! What a day.
This is the perfect way to get ready for the Kraken versus the Rangers tonight.
We've seen a lot of things here in Seattle.
We had to walk by the gum wall.
I thought it was just a small little piece of a wall.
What is going on here?
[Laughing]
Best way to get around Seattle right now. We're gonna go right to the rink
on these little scoots. Let's get it.
We are buzzin'! Let's go!
In the arena, first stop, we gotta get decked out.
Check out The Lair.
No doubt, best merch, best branding in the NHL.
Looking around, I mean—this, this is too much.
There is a spinning, floating jersey rack.
Rostislav Nasherov custom Kraken jersey coming soon?
- [Announcer:] Your Seattle Kraken!
- Let's go!
We got the hookup here. We're gonna head to the media hole.
They got us a little spot for warmies.
Head down there, get a few of the boys. Let's go.
We're gonna get you guys the best view ever of the warmies.
- [Announcer:] Kraken Nation, It's time to release the Kraken!
- [Cheering]
- And starting in goal, No. 31, Philipp Grubauer!
- [Fans:] Gruuuu!
- [Fans:] Oooh.
- I mean, that's just a nasty snipe.
Zero angle. Looked like it might've hit crossbar, but no, dead back of the net.
What a start here in Seattle. A couple good chances both ways.
1-0 for the Rangers right now. We've got a good view of the goal.
We'll see what happens here in the second
- Thank you so much.
- Great to meet you. Enjoy the game.
- Yeah. You too.
- Appreciate it.
Dude, Ohio represents out here.
What up? How we doin' brother?
- Good. How are you?
- Living the dream.
- What is this? What is going on here?
- So I made a sign that's spelled out in Russian.
- That is sick. Dude, are you kidding me?
- Jacob and Olly right here.
- Wow.
- Rangers suck!
- Thank you.
- Cool costume!
- I think it's official. Olly and Jacob On the Bench, they're worldwide.
- [Fan:] Yeah!
- [Cheering]
- [Foghorn blasting]
- Big period there for the Kraken, tied the game up.
Got to see it from multiple angles.
I was up top. John was down low. Time for the biggies.
We have the concessions coming in.
The important thing to note about the concessions here, it is cashierless.
There's cameras that follow you around the
store, and you don't have to do anything.
You just walk in, insert your credit card and grab whatever you want
off the shelves and then you're good to go.
Here we go.
What are we feeling today?
Don't mind if I do. How is it watching me right now?
I have no idea.
All right, water.
And just like that, no cashier needed. We're outta here.
There, there's just no way.
There's no way.
Wow. The future is now.
We got our Skittles. There's plants on the walls. There's no cashiers.
This is a dream come true.
And a good hockey game to go along with it.
We need a Seattle Kraken win.
I'm not the curse, OK? I'm not showing up and getting them a loss. Let's go.
Now we are going to the press lounge. We are going all over this building.
The fans are to the left. The ice is to the right.
Watch the game from here.
That was actually nasty. Adam Fox with a little bop bop,
double toe drag to the snipe. He is disgusting.
We need a miracle. Let's go.
- [Fans yelling]
How have they not scored one of these?
Two goals, one minute. Pick up your phone, hold it.
Final score, 3-1. RIP.
And that is gonna do it here in Seattle. A tough loss to end the night.
They just couldn't beat Igor. He popped off at the end.
There were so many good chances, but it was too little, too late.
It was a blast here in Seattle, though.
Getting to hang out with you guys, explore the arena
and show you everything behind the scenes here at Climate Pledge.
We'll definitely come back for another Seattle
game to prove that we are not the curse.
So a crazy night, still a good night.
Thank you guys for hanging out. I'm Nasher with B/R Open Ice,
and we're out. Peace.